allora buongiorno a tutti ecco vorrei
ringraziare gli organizzatori per aver
pensato di appunto mettere al centro
questo argomento
le donne e la diversità è un argomento
molto importante ma come sapete è un
argomento di cui si parla abbastanza
poco troppo poco
ancora oggi in italia e poi i risultati
li vediamo adesso come diceva qui la
nostra coordinatrice mi hanno chiesto di
venir via raccontare un po la mia la mia
storia la mia storia di donna acrobata
un po giocoliere una donna che si
destreggia tutti i giorni tra tanti
ruoli
un po mamma un po donna un po moglie un
po manager chi più ne ha più ne metta
però prima di prima di tutto vorrei
ricordare come si diceva prima che pavia
per me è una città speciale perché è qui
che ho studiato ormai troppi anni fa mi
sono laureata in ingegneria o studiato
in un collegio femminile e quindi già
allora ho avuto la possibilità di
apprezzare la ricchezza di questo
universo e credo che appunto
l'importanza di questo tipo di strutture
di istituzioni sia essenziale per
promuovere lo sviluppo e la presenza
delle donne nel mondo del lavoro
come dicevo io mi sono laureata qui mi
sono laureata che ormai quasi 20 anni fa
e una volta laureata ho preso sono
andata a lavorare sono andate a lavorare
in una società di consulenza americana e
una societa dove lavoravo tanto non
c'erano orari ma anche un mondo molto
interessante avuto la possibilità di
viaggiare di incontrare un sacco di
gente è un lavoro che portava via tutto
il mio tempo di giorno a volte anche di
notte ma devo dire che non mi pesava più
di tanto perché appunto la famiglia non
era proprio era lontanissima dai miei
pensieri
io quello che volevo era viaggiare
rendermi economicamente indipendente
crescere professionalmente quindi questa
storia del marito dei figli non solo
dare una priorità ma proprio sull'agenda
non compariva passano gli anni e poi
dieci anni dopo aver iniziato a lavorare
mi ritrovo in una stanza di ospedale con
in braccio questa neonata mio stessa
incredula perché francamente ci mio
marito con lo sai che abbiamo una figlia
non è stata una cosa facile da assorbire
ve lo garantisco
e quindi come tante donne della mia
situazione
mi sono chiesta che cosa faccio assenso
tornare a lavorare
posso io competere con degli uomini che
comunque dalla mattina alla sera l'unica
cosa che devono fare è pensare a
lavorare perché poi c'è qualcuno a casa
che pensa a tutto il resto
oppure mi conviene trovarmi un lavoretto
part time oppure non lavorare ha fatto
ma chi me lo fa fare andare a lavorare o
poi io non ho una famiglia che mi aiuta
su chi posso contare
e siccome io comunque non sono una che
si fascia la testa preventivo
ho cercato di organizzarvi mi sono
trovata un aiuto a casa e sono tornata a
lavorare perché devo dire che
onestamente l'idea di uccidere una parte
di me era un po frustrante
allora ho detto proviamoci e sono
tornata a lavorare e come è andata
ovviamente all'inizio è stato un bagno
di sangue totale perché ovviamente tu
passi da fare un lavoro a farne due
spesso e volentieri pure col turno di
notte non è una passeggiata di salute
però superata questa prima fase di
assestamento che anche un po dolorosa
diciamocelo
1 scopre che questi due ruoli questi due
lavori buona sostanza si sostengono e si
rafforzano a vicenda e quindi scopre che
in realtà il fatto di focalizzarsi su
una cosa sola non è vincente per niente
quindi il fatto di lavorare a me ha dato
comunque una serenità e un equilibrio
come madre perché pur non può pensare
improvvisamente come dicevo prima di
rinunciare a una parte di sé siccome
sono diventata madre adesso sono
un'altra persona no se io andavo a
lavorare fino al giorno prima ho bisogno
di andare a lavorare anche il giorno
dopo se nomadi ventole press di vanto
frustrata e un bambino che ha madre lo
sa non è che ha tanto bisogno di
mangiare o di dormire si ha bisogno
anche di quello però soprattutto bisogno
di un ambiente sereno quindi di essere
circondato da persone che sono serene
che sono a posto con loro stesse quindi
da questo punto di vista il fatto di
aver mantenuto un attività lavorativa
mi ha dato questo equilibrio e
dall'altra il fatto di essere diventata
madre mi ha aiutato molto nel lavoro
perché mi ha dato comunque un punto di
vista è una prospettiva sui problemi
lavorativi diversa molto più obiettiva
rispetto a prima per non contare il
fatto che sono anche diventata molto più
paziente con tutti però al di là di
questo devo dire che mi ha dato una
lucidità e comunque un senso pratico il
fatto di avere una famiglia a casa che
raramente ho trovato negli uomini
quindi in realtà è proprio il fatto di
riuscire a mantenere in equilibrio
queste sfere che è vincente
e ovvio che non è una cosa che succede
così per grazia ricevuta meno per quella
che è la mia esperienza organizzarsi
bene è fondamentale organizzarsi al
lavoro quindi non essere un one man show
costruirsi una squadra di persone che
sono persone in gamba sulle quali puoi
fare affidamento pianificare lavorare
per priorità e poi organizzarsi bene
anche a casa dico sempre al mio marito
io potrei vivere senza di te ma non
potrei vivere senza la mia tata che
veramente io non vivo senza te la perciò
l'organizzazione è l'elemento chiave
un altro elemento chiave è il fatto di
non pretendere di riuscire a fare tutto
ormai tantissime volte nell'arco di
questi anni la gente mi ha chiesto ma
come fai a fare tutto e io tutte le
volte rispondo che non faccio tutto non
faccio perché il punto non riuscire a
fare tutto
devo dire che come donne noi purtroppo
soprattutto in un paese come l'italia
spesso e volentieri siamo qualche modo
oppresse da un senso di colpa quando
andiamo a lavorare
noi comunque ci sentiamo colpevoli ci
sentiamo che comunque dobbiamo essere la
mamma perfetta la moglie perfetta la
figlia perfetta
tutto perfetto in questo senso di colpa
che non ho ben capito da dove arriva
nella nostra società se dalla religione
da che cosa non lo so però la verità che
non ha nessun senso cercare di fare
tutto in maniera perfetta
semmai il punto a cercare di portare il
bagaglio che si acquisisce in una sfera
dell'altra e viceversa cercando il più
possibile di liberarsi da tutti questi
sensi di colpa e l'altra cosa
l'altra domanda che mi fanno spesso è ma
come si fa a crescere professionalmente
a fare carriera in un mondo che comunque
ha dominato dagli uomini in un mondo
dove le donne sono discriminate
io quello che vorrei dire che io non mi
sono mai sentita particolarmente
discriminata come donna cui vi riporto
la mia esperienza professionale
probabilmente le statistiche dicono
qualcosa di diverso però io devo dirvi
che pur essendo comunque cresciuta
professionalmente in un mondo a
prevalenza maschile
nettamente a prevalenza maschile non ha
mai sentito particolare discriminazioni
perché la mia esperienza è stata che
quando tu sei una persona seria quando
ti impegni soprattutto quando porti i
risultati i tuoi capi sono solo contanti
i tuoi capi ti sostengono perché
banalmente tu gli fai fare bella figura
l'azienda funziona l'azienda fattura
quindi io questa discriminazione da
parte degli uomini
onestamente non l'ho vissuta è vero che
nessuno ti regala niente
se tu vai lì a piangere miseria
automaticamente fi squalificato questo è
certo
però la mia esperienza che le donne
passatemi il termine possono essere
molto più cattive determinate cocciute
della maggior parte degli uomini basta
solo che lo vogliano invece quello che
io ho vissuto sulla mia pelle è che
spesso e volentieri diciamocelo le donne
possono essere le più grandi nemiche
delle donne e in particolare ci sono
alcune specie di donne che sono
abbastanza pericolose almeno nella mia
esperienza quindi cioè il primo tipo
quello della donna
diciamo della donna mamma bene quella
che ti guarda sempre con occhio di
rimprovero perché tu non dedichi alla
famiglia tutto il tuo tempo perché tu
stai nata per servire gli altri e quindi
il fatto che tu vada a lavorare è
sostanzialmente inutile nella misura in
cui non c'è un bisogno c'è altrimenti
non si arriva alla fine del mese allora
perché diavolo vai a lavorare
poi c'è secondo tipo di donna quello che
pensa che fa carriera cercando di
sedurre il capo e quindi automaticamente
si crea questo pregiudizio da parte di
tanti uomini che se tu ce l'hai fatta al
lavoro ce l'hai fatta non perché hai
portato risultati ma perché ti sei
portato a letto qualcuno è anche questo
non aiuta per niente
e poi c'è il terzo tipo della donna che
lavora e che però si sente in
competizione solo con le altre donne
quindi se c'è un uomo che va avanti non
è un problema ma se c'è una donna
automaticamente deve farla fuori
e ovvio che non tutte le donne sono così
grazie al cielo
però è vero che in tanti casi le donne
possono creare seri problemi ad altre
donne in generale però io ritengo che
oggi il mondo del lavoro anche in italia
copriva si ricordavano alcune
statistiche che purtroppo non sono
confortanti cioè oggi in italia se non
ricordo male una donna su due o
addirittura a meno di una donna su due
lavora e se non ricordo male prima di
noi
no scusate dopo di noi c'è solo la
grecia quindi la settima potenza
industriale mondiale ma da questo punto
di vista siamo messi malissimo
quindi io credo che anche in italia il
mondo del lavoro stia comprendendo che
c'è spazio cioè sempre più spazio per le
donne
se non vogliamo continuare a scivolare
nelle classifiche di tutto il mondo e
dall'altra credo che le donne debbano
seriamente decidere di cogliere questa
opportunità l'opportunità di creare
valore all'interno del mondo del lavoro
quello che penso che tante volte debbano
avere un po più di fiducia in loro
stesse fiducia nel loro potenziale e un
potenziale che è veramente grande vi
ringrazio
[Applauso]